make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and you
guys have been asking me to make walking
dead content again for quite
some time so we're gonna test the waters
and we're gonna see how this does to
determine whether or not we cover more
walking dead content but before we get
into this list of the most iconic
weapons
in walking dead right in the walking
dead comics i want to tell you guys
about the walking dead survivors which
is the
ultimate strategy game and i want to say
thank you to the walking dead survivors
for sponsoring
this video so unless you've been living
under a rock you've likely heard of the
walking dead by robert kirkman one of
the single greatest comic stories ever
released well
as a compliment to the comic book series
alex developed the walking dead
survivors
the ultimate survival strategy game with
an original story and over 80 unique
characters now the game
is designed as a tower defense system
and it's amazing like literally in the
first 10 seconds
a bus comes crashing into a neighborhood
glenn comes out we're introduced to a
couple of new characters which is
awesome
you can throw dynamite at the walking
dead which is awesome but for those of
you guys who are unfamiliar with tower
defense this basically means
building different structures that serve
to block impede attack or even destroy
enemies and the choices you make on
where you position defensive elements is
an essential strategy of the genre which
has been around like
forever so how does all this work well
the survivors are essentially the heroes
of the game and they're all basically
characters from either the walking dead
comic series or they were created by lx
which is a really nice touch and each
group of survivors has their own
features and abilities along with skills
that grow and enhance based on the
experience level of each group but your
combat survivors can actually be trained
and promoted to a higher level
using training facilities as the game
goes on but moving on to the saviors
they essentially shape the main goal of
the game which is to drive them
out of the sanctuary in the middle of
the region map now something i do want
to point out is that this is going to
take something like two to three months
to pull off so it's definitely not one
of these deals where you play the game
for a week and then you basically beat
it i'm currently playing it right now
and i've actually got a clan in the game
called the robcor so you guys should
download it so we can go play it because
that would be amazing but jumping into
the list i don't want to spoil
everything for you guys i don't want to
spoil the whole game i want you guys to
go and play it and
and make sure you guys check the
description so you guys can download it
and then hang out with me
but i want to start this list right so
coming in at number 10 is carl's handgun
now here's the thing carl's handgun was
not really iconic in and of itself
because it's a handgun right
it's the the circumstance in which it
was used you guys remember in volume one
i think it was issue number six where he
killed shane that came out of nowhere
right and it was just like
wow like it was it was the craziest
thing like i had no idea that was gonna
happen i remember way back when
reading that story and then like
immediately he dies and i was just like
what and then just and there's like carl
just standing there holding the smoking
gun and i was like wow man like that's
why this is number 10 right just because
of the fact that it's the shock value
of of carl killing shane and at that
moment that's when carl's character
began to shift
and essentially turned into well really
the character who was more hardened and
just kind of had to do the things that
he needed to do in order to survive but
at number nine
i want to go into thomas's knife and
here's a crazy thing about this thomas's
knife was interesting because thomas was
the secret killer and thomas's knife
like for those of you guys who recall
whenever they got to the prison there
was a guy who was going around
and was basically killing everybody
right like in that in that comic series
there was a guy who was going around and
was killing people in the prison and you
didn't know who it was
and it created this this like super
amazing you know kind of like detective
story right where you kind of had like
figure out who it was it was doing all
this different stuff and it turned out
to be
thomas just one of the crazy inmates but
the fact that this guy managed to make
it through that far
all the way through volume three
seemingly without anybody knowing it was
him
was pretty mind-boggling coming in at
number eight is the commonwealth
soldiers bayonet machine guns now this
is actually a part of the story that we
didn't cover in the comic book run
so i'm afraid this is gonna be a little
bit of a spoiler for those of you guys
who don't know but the commonwealth is
what
really the closest you get to like a
fully unified society in the walking
dead right in the sense that it's just
like a giant combination of communities
much like alexandria was and so the
result of this
is that they're pretty well armed and
like i mean they've got like body armor
and all that kind of stuff but they've
got these automatic weapons with
bayonets on the end
and that's a genius theme because they
serve two purposes the first is that
they can shoot the walking dead at a
distance and the second is that if they
find themselves being surrounded they
can literally just start impaling them
in the head using a bayonet which is a
great idea but coming in at number seven
and i think this was gonna kind of
surprise people negan's knife now i
think a lot of people were
were probably expecting negan's knife to
be closer to the end uh and here's the
reason why right negan's knife this was
an amazing moment in the comics so
there's a point those are the guys who
remember alpha who led
basically the whispers and it was just
kind of like this great big huge group
of individuals who actually dressed up
as the walking dead
and uh just kind of roamed around and
then like they would actually take
people out they would sneak among them
there came a point where negan
managed to get out and then on behalf of
alexandria was seemingly nobody noticing
he went and he met with alpha right the
leader of the whispers and was kind of
like doing this whole bargaining thing
and was kind of like hey you know let's
talk to someone and then like you flip a
page and he just like
slices her neck and then cuts her head
off and it's the craziest thing right
just sits there and does it like i'm
recovering that and it was just like
like i was i was
all calm and i was like yeah like
negan's talking to this chick you know
and then he slices her throat and it was
like the craziest thing
i don't know if you guys remember that
but it was like it was one of the most
fun moments right so so nonetheless like
i put negan's knife at number seven
because of the significance of the
moment when negan killed
alpha now number six i put andrea's
sniper rifle and the whole reason behind
this is because
andrea was a marksman with this thing
this girl could hit a tic tac from like
a quarter mile away it was crazy how
accurate she was and it's one of those
things you didn't
you didn't really know it was kind of
the development of her character was
like once they put a sniper in her hand
she
she was actually training people on how
to shoot right so this girl was super
capable and it was one of those great
things like when the saviors first
showed up and all that kind of stuff it
was one of those great big huge things
where like they needed her right like
i'm not going to spoil what happens to
andrea
in the comic series because it's kind of
nuts but my vote here goes to andrea
for the number six spot now number five
is juanita sanchez's m60 machine gun and
spear
and here's a crazy thing so once they
start to get and explore the the
commonwealth area right the kind of
outskirts of it and whatnot they come
across juanita sanchez who actually goes
by the name princess but this girl
is carrying an m60 right this is a
turret gun man like like this
it's nuts right this is one of those
things you just sit in a window and
spray
and like this thing is it's the best
like i feel like it's the best weapon to
have
in some situation because she says that
she's like if ever i find myself being
surrounded by a horde i just sit back on
the lawn chair and open fire right and
that's
that's
exactly what it is man like you could
take your time right you got an m60
like woba tied you if it jams but like
you can take your time with that thing
but on the off
chance that walkers get too close or she
doesn't want to make any noise she has a
spear man and she talks about how it's
one of the best things because she's
like it's great for keeping your
distance
while killing the walking dead and it's
cool man like you're literally just like
spearing them through the head
but after that after number five we go
to number four
now this top four list this is when
things get a little wonky beta's
walking dead army i know this is
technically not
a weapon in the conventional sense but
he used the walking dead as a weapon
right so you guys so so after alpha was
killed
by negan and then basically the forces
of beta were more like beta was kind of
cast out and more or less defeated that
kind of stuff he ends up rounding up a
horde of like 10
000 walk of the walking dead and then
sends them to alexandria and just like
it's all in retaliation for alpha being
killed by negan it's
nuts and like they storm the place right
like that's what basically leads to
everybody having to bail out of
alexandria and then ultimately
discovering the commonwealth but like
it's nuts man like just sending an army
of 10 000 walking dead
into a town that's pretty insane but
following that we go to number three
and that's mercer's hatchet now i chose
mercer's hatchet because this guy
is pinpoint accurate right much like
andrew with a sniper rifle this guy like
dude when he throws that hatchet
whatever he throws at is getting hit and
that's just the way it is like he was
literally head shotting the walking dead
with like with a hatchet man just like
like the precision there was just
absolutely nuts it was cool right just
because of the fact that having a
hatchet and being able to be
so deadly accurate with that thing is
almost perfect because the walking dead
are already slow so all you have to do
is walk around with this hatchet and
just like throw it at them right now the
biggest issue you run into is if you
throw into a group of them and hopefully
you wouldn't be stupid enough
to do that right take a hatchet and
throw it into a group of like 10 of the
walking dead who are all close to each
other because like it's literally a
one-off man it's like firing a musket
like as soon as as soon as that shot's
fired you just run right there's nothing
you can do it's not the most ideal thing
but the precision under which he uses it
and the way that it can be used against
both the walking dead and the living
that's why i put that at number three
because it's sheer genius and it's
something that i'd never considered
before now coming in at number two i
feel like this is gonna be one that a
lot of people are gonna debate about
coming in at number two
lucille now i think a lot of people felt
like lucille should have been number one
but it's not i actually have a really
good pick for number one right i love i
love the name that i gave to number one
so number two
lucille right this is negan's baseball
bat but the reason why i put this at
number two is that while it is like a
baseball bath that he uses to like bash
on people it's the meaning behind it
right like he named it after his dead
wife and like it's the coolest thing
right like once you learn the backstory
of negan it's amazing how that whole
thing goes down but the fact that it had
some of the most iconic moments
in the entirety of the series and then
there's one point i'm not gonna tell you
why it happens but there's one point
where negan gets rid of lucille because
he's basically leaving his wife behind
he's like okay
i've moved on from my wife and he leaves
her behind and moves on to a better life
negan's story is amazing in the comics
like it's ridiculously good in the
comics but i chose that just because of
how
iconic this baseball bat is but coming
in at number one
michonne's toolbox now anybody who knows
what i'm talking
anybody who read the comics knows
exactly what i'm talking about here so
for those of you guys who don't know
when michonne with her katana or like
her sword which is amazing it almost
made
the list michonne sword almost made the
list right like it's i mean it's a sword
right you'd think it would just it would
make the list because it's a sword but
it didn't it didn't quite make it i felt
like there were other things that were a
little more impressive but during the
walking dead comics when they end up
discovering the governor
in woodbury and they end up michonne's
held captive by the governor who does
all kinds of just
terrible like terrible terrible terrible
things to her eventually they managed to
free michonne right and for the most
part
take out the guys at woodbury but
michonne takes her time with the
governor right in volume six she does
this
she gets her revenge on him and this
this is not for the faint of heart
literally she opens like she has like
this this just
treasure trove of little goodies she's
got an electric screwdriver that she
uses to drill holes through him she
nailed his penis to the floor
she gouged out his eye with a spoon she
cut off his
arm she pulled out his fingernails with
pliers and then caught a rise the wound
with an acetylene torch this girl
took it to him right like she went to
work on him but that's why i call it
michonne's toolbox right because it's
just
this this kind of collection of all
these little goodies that she uses but
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments section i'm curious which
one you guys thought shouldn't be on the
list which ones you guys thought should
be on the list but make sure you guys
check the description
and make sure you guys go get your hands
on the walking dead survivors so we can
hang out and we can play together and i
will catch you all later
peace
you